wir schauen einmal rein in die aktuelle
lage
der abou chaker klar der clan hat einen
palästinensischen hintergrund sein
oberhaupt arafat abou chaker der abou
chaker clan ist zahlenmäßig mit mehreren
hundert mitgliedern er das schlusslicht
dafür ist er wahrscheinlich am
bekanntesten zu ihrem zweifelhaften ruhm
gelangte die familie vor allem durch
ihre verwicklung in die deutsch rap
szene und arafats zerwürfnis mit dem
rapper bushido dessen management er
lange übernommen hatte auch der sohn des
clan-chefs stand jetzt vor gericht er
wird beschuldigt teil einer brutalen
überfall serie auf prostituierte zu sein
der remote lahn der plan hat einen
arabischen migrationshintergrund
plan oberhaupt ist ist mit 500 bis 1000
mitgliedern zählt er hier eher zu den
kleinen plans aber unterschätzen sollte
man die großfamilie nicht unter anderem
sollen sie für den einbruch in die
dresdner schatzkammer grünes gewölbe und
den raub der goldmünze aus dem berliner
bode museum verantwortlich sein der mir
klar er kommt aus dem libanon und ist
vor allem in niedersachsen vertreten
plan boss ist ibrahim mehr weit über
zwei dutzend türkisch libanesische
familien gehören zu den minis und so
besteht er aus mehr als 1000 mitgliedern
dem clan werden schwere fälle von
drogenhandel diebstahl und hehlerei
vorgeworfen
der all seinen klang der plan ist eine
weit verzweigte kurdisch arabische
großfamilie der plan boss mohamud als
sein der mittlerweile in der türkei lebt
mehr als 10.000 mitglieder hat der clan
illegale geschäfte mit drogen und waffen
zuhälterei geldwäsche körperverletzung
betrug und diebstahl sollen zur
tagesordnung erst als sein clans gehören
außerdem soll der plan auch in den
einbruch in die jugendabteilung des
berliner kadewe verwickelt gewesen sein
herr werden wenn man das jetzt sieht
also die namen sind bekannt die
straftaten sind bekannt für mich als
bürgerin es ist jetzt wirklich die frage
warum greift die justiz nicht ein dass
zunächst einmal darf man nicht glauben
das ist jetzt eine feststehende gruppe
wäre im übrigen auch sozialpolitisch
völlig falsch weil man muss neben den
ganzen polizeilichen und justiziellen
mitteln auch
kommunikative und soziale aspekte immer
bedeuten hatten das heißt was machen
weil ich mit denjenigen jungen menschen
die in einem solchen klar in einer
solchen form welche sind da aber raus
folgen für die müssen wir ein angebot
haben den dürfen wir nicht sagen ja der
witz war polizistin oder polizist werden
geh du mal in deinem klar zurück wir
wollen dich hier nicht haben dass genau
das nicht tun haben sie leicht wellig
lösung warum greifen wir da nicht ein
die namen sind bekannt die polizei
greift ein also im übrigen nicht nur mit
polizeilichen mitteln von der illusion
müssen wir uns auch lösen manchmal ist
das finanzamt in der bekämpfung der
kriminalität fast so wirkungsvoll wie
ein spezialeinsatzkommando der polizei
oder ein ordnungsamt oder eine
gesundheitsbehörde eine schulbehörde die
wir alle in der mithaftung nehmen müssen
und das auch tun es finden ja sehr sehr
ausgefeilte konzepte mittlerweile statt
ich habe mich gefreut in neukölln hat
falko liecke beispielsweise das immer
wieder beschrieben seit vielen jahren
ist er damit beschäftigt auch
sozialpolitische ansätze in den schulen
in den familien zu wirken aber eben
nicht nur mit polizei in nordrhein
westfalen werden alle diese behörden
miteinander verbunden es gibt
schwerpunkt kommissariate
schwerpunktstaatsanwaltschaft das genau
der richtige ansatz aber seit einigen
wenigen jahren hält diese clans haben
wir seit 30 40 jahren in deutschland wir
werden die nicht in fünf jahren
bekriegen ich glaube da brauchen wir
ihre 50 wenn er versagt denn hierher
frauen wollen wir mal eins nach tragen
haben wir nicht prinzipiell eine schelte
der polizei einseitig geben wollen es
ist auch der dahinter stehende staat
wenn die leute also die marschieren
sofort auch mit einer reihe von hoch
bezahlten anmelden und wir unsere
strafprozessrecht kind und all dies weiß
dass ein großteil der leute
hat kürzester zeit wieder auf freien fuß
ist strafen folgen nicht auf dem fuß
nach monaten sind gerichtsprozesse bis
dahin ist der mensch längst dem libanon
oder sonst zu abgetaucht oder anderen
deutsch also der staat versagt nein gehe
dahin nicht mehr bereit das heißt diese
gesellschaft ich bin ja dafür dass
soziales getan wird im übrigen es gibt
in neukölln nicht zehn nicht 20 es gibt
hunderte tausende menschen die ihn im
sozialen bereich tätig sind die
sozialarbeiter sind die gespräche führen
die gruppen therapien anbieten und alles
mögliche das stelle ich alles nicht in
frage aber der staat zeigt nicht flagge
ich habe polizisten gefragt warum sie
nicht eingreifen in der hermannstraße
als eine u bahn geprügelt wurde da der
gesagt meine kolleginnen nicht gehen hin
und dann haben die fünf zeugen die sagen
die haben gesagt hier anpacken brut
sodann wird das aufgeschriebene
strafantrag löschel profiling [ __ ]
brot schon und die kriegen immer recht
so weil die natürlich zusammenhalten wie
pech und schwefel wir müssen mal die
wahl haben es noch einmal ganz ganz
kleine historische profiling kein
problem also ist es nicht wirklich so
dass ich jetzt zum beispiel wenn wir
jetzt mal ehrlich sind als blonde frau
wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht direkt
kontrolliert werde und andere schon er
gibt es nicht auch wäsche profiling
malerische profilen gibt es nicht und
das einzige fall in deutschland den
einzelnen fall gibt es immer aber es
gibt kein strukturelles problem und es
gibt schon gar nicht dass sozusagen als
polizeiliche einsatz maxime das wird er
gelegentlich behauptet dass polizei wenn
sie in bestimmten gebieten kontrollen
vornehmen wahrnehmung ihres gesetzlichen
auftrags übrigens und dabei polizeiliche
erfahrung und die augenblick situation
berücksichtigt dann ist das recht
profiling sind ja in berlin in einer
ganz anderen situation in berlin macht
ja der gesetzgeber ein gesetz das
sogenannte anti diskriminierungsgesetz
da steht dann drin dass derjenige der
behauptet diskriminiert worden zu sein
von der polizei die polizei dann in die
pflicht versetzt zu beweisen dass sie
nicht diskriminiert hat also völlig
absurder zustand der hier stattfindet
aber ich erlebe das ja immer auch weil
bei der bundespolizei die in den
grenznahen regionen den gesetzlichen
auftrag hat beispielsweise illegale
migration zu bekämpfen und zu verhindern
und dass sie bei personenkontrollen
nicht erkennbar 80 jährige oma
kontrolliert beispielsweise eine gruppe
die sich auffällig verhält die gepäck
bei sich hat das zu kontrollieren ist
und die möglicherweise zu dem
personenkreis gehört der überhaupt in
frage kommt bei der illegalen migration
dass sie die kontrollieren liegt auf der
hand alles andere wäre übrigens blödsinn
und das würde auch rechtswidrig seien
das was ich gelegentlich aus der politik
höre dass man beispielsweise um racial
profiling zu verhindern jede achte oder
zehnte person kontrollieren soll das ist
natürlich völlig absurd und es wäre auch
rechtswidrig denn ich darf in die man
kontrollieren nur weil er die achte oder
zehnte besucher frage ich einmal heilige
kuh antonia wie sehen sie das also wenn
wir über racial profiling sprechen muss
ich schon sagen ich gucke den arafat
apotheker an er sieht sehr ähnlich wie
mein vater aus meinem ein israelischer
man sieht auch nicht sehr sehr anders
aus
und ja also mein mann ist komplett
israel ich bin halb deutsch halb israel
in mein mann total israeli wir leben
schon seit fünf jahren in berlin und
natürlich fehlt auch mein mann mal sehr
oft dass er anders angeguckt wird
wenn wir jetzt reden warum der staat
versagt hat kann ich nur sagen wir sehen
uns nicht nur ähnlich araber und
israelis wir haben wir kommen auch
irgendwie von eine sehr ähnliche kultur
familien kultur wie wollen wir
eigentlich diese jugendliche oder diese
junge männer von den clans rauskriegen
wenn wir den in deutschland nichts
anderes anbieten die kriegen liese klahn
nicht nur klima kriminalität wie kriegen
auch ein familiengefühl das tun die
deutschen denen nicht anbieten wenn sie
eine gute frage wie würde ich gern
direkt an herr siegel weitergeben wie
wir es schaffen dass wir sie auch raus
holen
ich glaube der ansatz ist nicht man
sollte jetzt auf teufel komm raus
versuchen menschen irgendwo raus suchen
sondern da muss genügend angebote
schaffen dass jeder mensch irgendwo
hingehen kann wo er sich aufgenommen
fühlt ich bin nicht dafür dass man
gesetze für arme kinder macht ich bin
dafür dass man gesetze für kinder macht
und ich bin dafür dass man angebote
verschafft und das machen wir wir sind
nicht programm orientiert sondern wir
sind beziehungs orientiert ich glaube
das ist das wesentliche das was ich
vorhin schon sagte das vertrauen
aufgebaut werden muss dass man vertrauen
hat ich bin 27 jahre lang in berlin
hellersdorf ich bin mit der arche
deutschlandweit viele jahre am gleichen
ort aber vor allem mit den gleichen
mitarbeitern mit den gleichen menschen
und das sozialsystem was wir heute haben
man finanziert von einem haushaltsjahr
zum anderen dann werden mitarbeiter
ausgetauscht ist fehlen diese
ansprechpartner die leute die ihnen
bestimmte bezirk und bestimmte gebiete
sind sind entweder ausgebrannt und
schnell weg sie halten gar nicht mehr
durch weil sie nicht das drückt rückhalt
haben und ich glaube es ist wichtig dass
diese ansprechpartner die das vertrauen
der menschen auch der kleinkinder der
klaren jugendlichen haben die müssen da
sein und zwar hier und das ist das was
ich schon lange wirst du langfristig da
sie müssen nachhaltig haben arbeiten
eins unserer konzepte und interessant
ist dass jedes kind in jeder art jeden
neuen mitarbeiter in deutschland ohne
absprache fragt wie lange bleibst du ja
aber wir sagen auch wenn der projekt
orientiert aber wir arbeiten 100
projektorientiertes chancen aus wir
wechseln aus wir sind aber keine keine
bank die ihre manager aussortieren
müssen sondern wir arbeiten mit menschen
väter und mütter sind in der regel auch
über jahre in der familie und erziehen
ihre kinder unterstützen und das
brauchen wir in unserem sozialsystem
dann wird das funktionieren und das
funktioniert ja seit jahrzehnten in
deutschland nicht